Sister Wives star Gwendolyn Brown is
engaged on Wednesday the 21 year old
daughter of Christine and Cody Brown
shared the exciting news on Instagram
Gwendolyn exclaimed in the caption I'm
engaged alongside a few snaps of The
Proposal with her new fiance Beatrice
the setting was super romantic the
couple sitting on a blanket in the snow
with candles around them it's just been
fabulous gwendolyn's also showing off
her new bling in this mirror selfie you
can see the ring which appears to be an
emerald cut diamond with some stunning
clusters
you talk close to my kids and it seems
having Mama Christine and sister
Isabelle close by came in handy for
pulling off the special moment Gwendolyn
tagged them in her proposal pics a hint
that her fam gave her the assist before
popping the question Isabel also shared
Gwen's post on her Instagram story a
cute proud sister moment this season on
Sister Wives fans learned more about
gwendolyn's sexuality I am bisexual I
think I probably have some influence on
their dating life possibly maybe more so
in the past now I try not to meddle
um at all gwendolyn's love life came up
during a conversation while helping
Isabel pack for college
not very nice very nice yeah a big boy
I'm sorry what do you mean it's about
what it's pregnant you can't talk to me
like that I'm bisexual I'm not only
attracted to women I'm also attracted to
men and people that fall under other
gender spectrums and for Christine it
didn't exactly come as a surprise when
Mariah told us that she was gay
immediately I thought oh
so is Gwendolyn I knew immediately and
we've had just great conversations about
it Mariah is Christine's former sister
wife Mary's Child who now goes by Leon
they came out as transgender in June and
their Journey played out on the TLC
Series in 2017. that she knows herself
and understands herself and is willing
to accept who she is is something to be
celebrated but we've tried to do with
our own family is just allow that space
for each child to grow up and really
Embrace what is that they want to
embrace looks like a Sister Wives
wedding is in the near future congrats
to Gwendolyn and Beatrice
[Music]
foreign